have you been holding off on Dark Souls
3 well now might be the right time to
pick it up if you want the game and all
of its DLC in one neat package I'm Matt
and this GameSpot news oh I'm already
dead
Dark Souls 3 the fire fades edition
includes the base game and both
expansions ashes of aerion del and the
Ring City were previously only available
in the $25 season pass or as separate
$15 purchases but now you'll be able to
get everything in one $50 package it's
available on the ps4 and Xbox one but
it's not clear if it's gonna make its
way to the PC in North America we'll
report back if anything more is
announced so be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to stay up on that Dark Souls
3 received an 8 out of 10 in game spots
review and even made it into our best
games of the year list the expansions
also earned positive reviews and we're
noted for having excellent boss battles
and great conclusions on top of all that
we've got a bunch of awesome Dark Souls
3 content on our channel so why don't
you check out an older episode of the
lobby where we discuss whether it's
worth returning for the DLC
[Music]